[Música]
miren seguramente ustedes habrán oído
decir a los emprendedores o si ustedes
son empresarios pues que hacer empresa
en colombia es muy duro
y que es a pesar de las dificultades que
logramos salir adelante
como estaban diciendo nuestras
presentadoras del día de hoy que además
son unas de mis ídolos pues mi historia
hoy es un poco diferente yo vengo a
contarles cómo esas dificultades que nos
presenta colombia nos han hecho una
empresa más fuerte y quiero llevarlos en
un viaje en el tiempo y que nos situemos
en los años 2001 2002 2003 y no sé si
ustedes se acuerdan lo que era en ese
momento colombia no sé si ustedes se
acuerdan de las pescas milagrosas de la
bomba del nogal del secuestro de ingrid
betancourt y de un montón de personas
más de esa cantidad de camiones quemados
en las vías colombia estaba viviendo una
guerra muy fuerte muy activa
y a mi socio si a mí se nos ocurrió la
peor idea
en realidad nunca hicimos un business
plan no pensamos en el tamaño de mercado
no pensamos en cuáles eran los riesgos y
decidimos que queríamos llevar por
colombia' a niños de colegios de bogotá
a zonas remotas para que conocieran
y pues ustedes debe estar diciendo como
ok si la teoría del mundo
de repente mi trabajo consistía en
llegar a colegios a donde los rectores y
adonde los papás a decirles no miren no
se afanen que ese retén de la guerrilla
que había en san agustín ya lo quitaron
la semana pasada entonces vamos a pasar
y ya no hay nadie y no hay ningún
problema y la pesca milagrosa que era en
la carretera medellín eso sólo pasa de
noche y nosotros vamos a pasar puro a
mediodía
entonces no no hay ningún problema
tampoco y y día a día yo estaba
diciéndoles que es que tocaba ir a sus
sitios que tocaba conocer el amazonas y
tocaba subir a la guajira y había que
conocer san antero córdoba
y
ustedes debe estar siendo bueno como
hicieron estas personas para que su
empresa haya sido un emprendimiento que
pues que esté más o menos exitoso
tres factores son los que yo creo que
nos ayudaron a sacar esta empresa
delante y es lo que quiero compartir con
ustedes hoy
el primero es la pasión y la
perseverancia
nosotros puede que hayamos estado locos
pero estábamos convencidos de que los
niños bogotanos especialmente y los
niños colombianos que viven en las
principales ciudades tenían que conocer
su país nosotros no podemos creer que
esos niños todos conozcan miami nueva
york pero no tengo ni idea donde de san
antero córdoba y que después vayan a ser
los próximos emprendedores los próximos
empresarios los próximos ministros y no
sepan cuál es ese país que tienen que
gobernar o al que le tienen que cambiar
el rumbo entonces realmente estábamos
convencidos de que esto y estamos
convencidos de que lo que hacemos le
cambia la historia al país y que lo que
hacemos construye patria porque estamos
convencidos que cuando un niño de bogotá
que se mueve entre el colegio y su casa
o su club
se va para la sierra nevada de santa
marta y sube ciudad perdida y conversa
con los guías y aprende sobre san antero
córdoba y también conoce la tatacoa y
villanueva pues entiende un poquito más
del país en el que está
lo que pasa es que esa pasión no era
suficiente porque esa pasión pues es la
que nos da y la perseverancia esas ganas
pero necesitábamos algo que fuera un
poquito más el sustento algo que era
bueno listo chevere la idea pero que hay
detrás
y entonces nos tocó pasar de la pasión a
la operación y nos tocó volvernos una
empresa operativa y entonces la
operación es lo segundo más importante
que ha logrado que nuestra empresa salga
adelante nos volvimos robustos
operacionalmente empezamos a tener
médicos 24 horas para todos nuestros
programas seguimiento satelital para
saber en dónde están todos los niños en
todo momento un servicio de búsqueda y
rescate que hace posible que llegue un
helicóptero y rescate a un niño en la
mitad de la selva teléfonos satelitales
para nunca perder la comunicación y día
a día nuestro departamento operativo
estaba pensando cómo hacer para tener
los estándares operacionales
más alto nivel
tenemos contactos con las fuerzas
armadas para saber si los sitios son
peligrosos avisamos a la policía de
carretera cuando estamos pasando y
estamos robusteciendo todo el tiempo
para que entonces los papás y los
colegios digan ok ya nos convencieron
con la idea de que estos tienen pasión
pero les creemos es que efectivamente
van a hacer que unos viajes sean seguros
y nos empezó a funcionar y nos empezó a
funcionar y empezamos a hacer viajes con
niños y empezamos a mostrarles este país
pero nos empezó a pasar una cosa que no
fue tan chévere y es que nos empezó a
saber acacho en realidad pues sí ya
estábamos como funcionando pero es que
hacer empresa en colombia es muy duro y
entonces pues ésta se volvió nuestra
típica frase maldito país maldito país
porque es que entonces aparecía la
noticia de volvieron a volar el la
carrilera del 30 y del cerrejón la
maldito país y se cancela olvida de la
guaira y entonces volvieron a quemar un
camión en la carretera al huila y
entonces ya no podemos ir el atacó y lln
e hizo paro armado por las carreteras de
boyacá y ya no podemos ir al páramo se
está maldito país y entonces todo el día
en la oficina todos estábamos tratando
de sacarlo adelante pero maldito país
y de repente nosotros es una cosa que
nos cayó el cielo nos cayó del cielo y
yo diría que es lo que cambió la
historia de nuestra compañía para
siempre y literalmente nos cayó el cielo
fenómeno de la niña del 2011
esa es la carretera que conectaba día
con bogotá y debajo de todo eso está la
universidad la sabana
miren se inundó colombia se inundó
colombia en el 2011 llovió el agustín
goás y reporta que es el fenómeno de la
niña más fuerte de los últimos 100 años
más de 2000 inundaciones reportadas más
de 700 derrumbes en diferentes vías 9
pueblos tuvieron que ser cambiados de
sito de sitio porque los ríos se los
llevaron y así como empezó a llover pues
uno a uno se fueron cayendo todos
nuestros programas el 90 por ciento
y en ese momento dijimos ok esto ya es
un tema no solamente de la carretera del
cerrejón teníamos dos opciones o seguir
diciendo maldito país y la realidad es
que pues nosotros teníamos clarísimo que
es que en un país como colombia el
fenómeno de la niña genera eso en un
país desarrollado pues llueve y ya
y la opción era seguir siendo maldito
país no teníamos otra opción
que fue la opción que tomamos que es una
opción totalmente fue opuesta y fue
decir que llueva es culpa nuestra
y decidimos que la lluvia iba a ser
nuestra culpa y que si llovía y se caían
nuestros programas era culpa nuestra
algo tan ridículo como decir que la
lluvia es culpa de uno porque pues la
realidad es que si yo no controlo
no soy sampedro
yo no controlo el clima pero la lluvia
es culpa mía
y eso es una forma de ver la vida y ese
fue el momento en mi que nuestra
compañía cambió de la operación a la
mentalidad y esa es la tercera cosa el
tercer factor que quiero compartir con
usted es la mentalidad que llueva es
culpa nuestra viene de un término en
psicología que llaman locus de control y
el locus de control es la percepción que
tenemos los seres humanos sobre un hecho
no es lo que realmente está pasando es
lo que yo creo que está pasando y uno
puede tener un locus de control interno
o un locus de control externo si uno
tiene un locus de control externo todo
lo que pasa es culpa de algo externo y
yo siempre voy a tener la percepción de
que es culpa de alguien más entonces
cuando llego tarde es culpa el trancón y
los ciudadanos le echamos la culpa
siempre al alcalde de turno y siempre la
culpa es de alguien distinto entonces
cuando no me funcionan mis relaciones
sentimentales siempre la culpa es del
otro y cuando me rajo en el parcial es
culpa el profesor o cuando me bajan a mi
niña en el parcial es culpa el profesor
porque es que mi hija si estudió
obviamente es culpa el profesor
y la culpa es del de al lado
el locus de control interno pero el otro
lado pues dice lo contrario yo soy
culpable de todo lo que me pasa así sea
ridículo
yo soy culpable de haber llegado tarde
porque sabiendo que hay trancón pues no
calculé salir con más tiempo yo soy el
responsable de que una relación
sentimental no me funcione porque pues
la realidad es que algo algo tenía que
haber hecho para que funcionara mejor yo
soy el responsable de saber que si el
profesor es el profesor que rafa a todos
pues tengo que estudiar un poquito más
y yo decido echarme la culpa de todo lo
que me pasa
está comprobado que las personas las
empresas e incluso los países que tienen
locus de control interno alto son más
exitosos porque tienen la capacidad de
prevenir sabiendo que todo lo que les va
a pasar es culpa de ellos o tienen la
capacidad de que cuando algo les pase es
decir que hubiera podido hacer yo
para que eso no pasará y que podría
hacer para que no me vuelva a pasar en
vez de echar la culpa a lo externo lo
cual es externo entonces no tengo
ninguna posibilidad de cambiarlo
y pues la lluvia para volver con nuestra
historia continuó
el 2011 se alargó hasta el 2012 siguió
lloviendo pero ya en nova estábamos
viendo las cosas distintas nosotros ya
estábamos en ese momento sabiendo que si
llovía acerca de los programas era culpa
nuestra y entonces decidimos cambiar
nuestras circulares y meter sombrillas y
ponchos encausados botas de caucho
cambiar los campings por hoteles y
arrancamos
y así como la lluvia pues han venido
otras cosas ha venido más guerra ha
venido chikungunya ha venido el cica y
es culpa nuestra
y si los programas se caen por eso por
esos efectos es culpa nuestra y las
personas que entran a trabajar ahora lo
primero que aprenden es que en nuestra
compañía nosotros nos echamos la culpa
de todo y nunca nos van a ver decir que
es que los papás no le dan las
circulares entonces les hacemos vídeos
porque si no las leen es culpa nuestra
y de esa manera aunque es un poquito más
difícil somos responsables de todo lo
que nos pasa es una forma de ver la vida
nosotros tenemos la peor idea del mundo
y la teoría del mundo la pudimos llevar
adelante y hoy en día no solamente
viajamos en colombia sino que veamos a
más de 18 países abrimos oficinas en los
eeuu
estamos viajando con unos de los
colegios más importantes del planeta
llevando niños a conocer sitios que no
nos hubiéramos podido imaginar viajes a
marruecos al tri lanka a malawi a cuba-
galápagos todas las semanas tenemos
niños viajando y conociendo diferentes
lugares y porque lo logramos porque
colombia nos hizo más fuertes primero
nos regaló la pasión la pasión de decir
necesitamos que estos niños conozcan su
país y eso no nos hubiera pasado en un
país que no fuera colombia porque en los
otros países si se puede viajar y en
este no
necesitamos volvernos buenas
operacionalmente y volvernos buenos
operacionalmente era montar unas
expediciones en un país en guerra eso no
nos hubiera tocado hacer si hiciéramos
viajes en un país perfecto y la realidad
es que esa operación la tuvimos que
hacer tan robusta que cuando llegamos a
otros países teníamos los estándares
operativos más altos del mercado porque
nadie más planea viajes para un país en
guerra y nos regaló una mentalidad una
mentalidad que hoy en día la usamos en
nuestra vida diaria y en nuestro trabajo
todo el tiempo y es lo que yo quiero
además regalarles el día de hoy depende
de cada uno de ustedes porque para
nosotros se llama la guerra el invierno
el cica para ustedes se puede llamar su
profesor su novio el dólar diferentes
problemas que tendrán ustedes en sus
negocios depende de cada uno si quieren
echarle la culpa a todo lo que está
pasando o si quieren más bien ser los
que controlan la situación muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]